if you are in this area of the room what
would you like
a wrap about
genghis khan yeah
oh
popular and you said that's so cool you
didn't even like you didn't even change
your versions when genghis khan
yeah
it's weird isn't it because like usually
you shout out the name of a rapist but
people don't cheer
but
no come on right
it's just that in the past
right it feels like if you're like oh he
raped that's a bad thing but if you're
like he raped and pillaged you like that
sounds exciting
the vikings raped and pillaged across
europe
pillaging
that
okay genghis khan because like well like
twenty percent of the world's population
wasn't half his dna is because he pulled
it out of it
great genghis khan amazing let's come to
uh this area of the room let's get our
next suggestion from you guys what's
your favorite
feudalism
i'm just saying that it's going to be
real boring for that whole portion
obviously i know what it is because
oxford
middle of the room what would you like
to wrap about
vasectomy is that a suggestion for this
one
okay vasectomy great um
vasectomy feudalism and genghis khan
yeah no i know
let's come over to the corner over there
what do you guys want to wrap up
country jumping have you done one or
more yeah ah how many just one just
did you do it on your own or with a
friend who's sadly no longer here
where did you do it from new zealand new
zealand yeah it's all [ __ ] sweet
isn't it because you go the opposite way
you're all children shut up
the dumbest joke ever and people were
here
what would you like around about
russia
russia okay let's let's kind of zoom in
on that be more specific what about what
about russia
or what about putin
riding a horse
riding a horse and his hairstyle do you
call
going thin on top a hairstyle
okay so putin riding a horse and his
hairstyle bungee jumping in new zealand
genghis khan don't worry okay
feudalism
why do you think i've forgotten it
what's wrong you're looking at this and
oh okay cool do you only call your
children by the order they were born in
this then lovely people um it's going to
be a freestyle rack as i said that's a
right made up on the spot based entirely
on your suggestion it's uh it's pretty
exciting you seem very skeptical
including my mind who said genghis khan
but don't worry just a little bit that's
all i want um and yeah don't worry it's
not being near as atrociously
embarrassingly tokenly bad you're
expecting a privately educated
middle-class white british boy to be so
uh i'm going in right now we've got the
hop and we got the hit i wanna cut off
the little tentacles with the snip
moving all the tubes maybe get a clip
put it down there now doctors say that
it's difficult you can't reverse it i'll
be wanking after it because i've heard
it you've got to make sure the testicles
are empty you used to have sperm in
there like plenty they used used
but now it's empty dusty and grey is
just one seminal vesicle in the sack
like i remember in the day when all the
way back i would put out lots of sperm
every so many years i was waiting my
turn they were swimming for the egg they
were going to be making all the features
with the ovary and then it's gone
probably under the knife with the
suggestion of your lady wife like
i don't wanna get filled with a baby and
i'm not on the pill i don't want iud
contraceptive so off to the doctor you
check it you're like have you got a
license and a medical degree or is it
just in the back alley with the whole
[Music]
let me see this like feudalism imma
serve right at the bottom of the pyramid
farming in the fields to feed my wife
and my little kids then i get up to the
lord above you got the knights and i
want to give them a shot and let me put
this in a great earth context it's a
system that keeps boots on the neck of
the people in the uk in medieval times
they were getting all the sheets they
were pleasing mine they were trying to
find and give it up to the king and he
would serve the barons when they were
asking they would bust to the knights
they would get an army see i told you
you guys wouldn't go above me
[Music]
medieval history is totally boring well
let me take it back yeah this'll do a
charm i'm a guy coming
[Music]
on his horse and then it fell over and
of course he used to own a large area a
big empire of the land but sadly on his
horse expired he got bucked off and i
think you're like this didn't it explode
like appendicitis then it killed him
well some people theorize if you want to
get down from up high the quickest way
to return to something is going down on
a court bungee
[Music]
you smell a jumping little whiff of
something you're like will it's so fun
to do this but as i'm going up and down
oh i do [ __ ] in my own head why did i go
down here um runny hell no i'm looking
up on the bridge and the guy who did it
before me in russia he's real big he'd
be looking down like oh i'm assuming you
don't know me
but people say i'm the handsomest man in
leningrad today
we gotta rename absurd i'll be out in
moscow and saint petersburg where am i
of course on the back of a horse
and the man on the horse is longer than
me but i give him a nice sugar lamp than
i lead communism
[Applause]